bloodied bandaged faces and in shock
husband and wife mikola and luke miller
tried to comfort each other
they were inside the shopping mall when
the missile hit they'll choose what the
question i flew head first and splinters
hit my body the whole place was
collapsing i then landed on the floor
and i don't know if i was conscious or
unconscious i didn't understand anything
i opened my eyes and i saw a big piece
of rubble was on top of me
i started to scream help me water was
coming from somewhere the water woke me
up
michala describes the scene
i saw lots of wounded people burned
people some were covered in blood
one girl fell down and we helped pull
her along
hospital staff worked all night to treat
the dozens of wounded people
but not everyone brought to the hospital
survived
outside people register the names of
friends and family they cannot find
me
i was working and i heard the explosion
and i saw the fire
i put my friend's name on the list but
we have no information about whether
he's alive or not a burnt out shell is
all that remains of the shopping center
emergency services search in the rubble
for survivors and remains
julia was working in a shop across the
street the attack happened
they hate us
i'm bella russian i was born in belarus
this is my fatherland i'm ashamed
president vladimir zelinsky said there
were around a thousand people inside
them all at the time
today's russian strike on a shopping
center in cremenchuk is one of the most
daring terrorist acts in european
history a peaceful city an ordinary
shopping center inside women children
ordinary civilians
ukraine's national security and defence
council said preliminary data suggested
the russian strike was from one of two
x-22 cruise missiles fired from an
aircraft
it said the other hit the city's sports
stadium
kremenchuk has been hit by russian
missiles at least twice before but they
didn't leave this scale of death and
destruction
moscow says it's trying to avoid
civilian casualties but hardly a day
goes by when a civilian isn't either
killed or injured in a russian missile
strike a long way
from the front lines charles stratford
al jazeera kiev